Loyalty to the Khan.
I didn't check.
Oh my god, I have to lower it even more.
Like that.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
This is the loudest game ever.
It's so loud.
Wait, okay.
Today's stream is incredibly scuffed.
Because my...
This game just broke my computer.
And it thinks that my left monitor is on the right.
And so I have to think about when I want to go over to my right monitor.
I have to go to the left.
And I just had this...
Okay, and also the game is so tiny for me.
But I just had a genius moment.
I'm gonna play through OBS.
Then I can scale it.
Oh my god, I can see the game.
I might be a genius.
Oh wait, no I can't.
I don't think this game is played with controller.
It seems like this game is played with mouse and keyboard.
It's keyboard only?
Okay, nevermind.
I have to play it really tiny.
It's like the size of my thumb.
It's so small.
I've been having issues with my...
With my... What's it called?
My monitors.
And so I don't want to change the resolution because only just today did they start getting a little bit...
Maybe not messed up.
I can still play looking at OBS, maybe.
The 4K life.
Don't upgrade to 4K monitors, you guys.
Don't do it.
You'll regret it.
Don't... You don't need to see in 4K.
The human eyes was not meant for this.
Don't do it.
It's only made my afterlife miserable.
But also I did it because I wanted pink monitors.
I got to meet David Hayter yesterday.
He was indeed pretty good.
He's such a nice guy.
He's so silly.
I wanted to try mentioning this once more.
You can try Windows Power Toys crop and lock.
I don't have that.
I do not have that, unfortunately.
But also if I touch the window...
Look how big my cursor is.
If I touch the window, like if I try to make it bigger or anything...
Wait, why isn't it moving?
My cursor.
That's weird.
If I... What's the word?
Oh, if I make it bigger, it ruins it.
Spank!
Thank you for the haka so far!
Too late.
Already 4K.
Here's some love for Metal Gear Solid.
Thank you!
Your cursor is moving though?
No, no.
I meant like... It's supposed to be dancing.
Me dancing.
I can just paint the housing for a regular monitor.
No!
Bad!
You can't!
No!
It has to be all over pink!
What do you mean paint?
Who does that?
What do you want it to look like?
Oh my gosh, it would look horrible.
No!
I wanted pink monitors!
Anyway, I'm not here to complain.
We're here to game.
Merry Gear Solid.
I'll stop complaining about the size, I think.
Windows has a magnifier feature.
I don't think you understand how broken my computer is right now at this very moment.
So I don't want to do anything more.
I had to already restart it like three times, okay?
So, please.
F it, we ball.
Yeah, baby!
Let's try.
Let's do a new game.
Oh, enter?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Shift?
Nothing equipped.
You can make distractions by...
Oh, hugging a wall and pressing control.
Look at me, I'm Santa!
Control.
What am I doing?
Oh, I'm knocking.
Is it a birthday?
Yesterday was my 30th birthday.
When the mint plush comes I'm going to take her to eat some yummy cake to celebrate.
Oh my gosh, it might be a mint though.
Happy birthday, Merry Baby!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Merry Baby.
Always and forever a baby.
Happy birthday!
Okay, I think we are getting timed, right?
I don't care about...
There is voice acting in this?
Tiny Tim?
Ebenezer E?
Military surveillance crafts have been circling the skies in response to the 9-11 attack 6 years ago.
What?
6 years ago?
Why?
The traditional way.
We can't risk having you spotted soaring through the sky on a sleigh.
With the nation on high alert as it is, there's far too great of a chance you'll be branded a national threat.
So that's why I'll be delivering gifts by foot I presume?
Precisely.
This is a top secret covert mission.
From this point on, we'll be referring to each other by code name.
Major Tim!
Solid Santa!
What is happening?
Top most floor.
Why?
Not the naughty children!
This is a stealth mission.
You must not be discovered or the mission will be a failure.
Do whatever it takes to stay out of the enemy's field of vision.
To make things easier, you'll need to make use of any tools you find in the house.
I'll be giving you advice and instructions via codec.
My frequency is 012.25.
Commencing Operation Secret Santa.
What's this?
What is...
OK, I have to look through OBS I think.
Maybe I... OK, let me try...
Hold on.
Oh, to the left?
Take it back now, y'all.
Windowed projector.
To the right.
Maybe if I watch through the window, it will be fine.
OK.
Oh, sorry.
One hop this time.
Alright, we're Santa, baby.
Yeah, they're asleep.
Oh, a trap?
Hugging walls.
I think this music might drive me crazy.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, Naughty Child.
What is this game?
You were discovered!
Guys, I'm not gonna make it.
How does this kid have such good vision?
How do I run faster?
Santa Claus.
How do I get around this kid?
He's gonna see me for sure.
This game is on European extreme difficulty.
Actually though...
OK, hold on.
Alright, once he leaves...
Go!
Oh my gosh, how am I supposed to...
Oh my god.
Wait, so all he does is run up to the wall...
and then waits for Santa again?
I have nothing.
I can't...
I wish I could punch him.
I have nothing.
Wait, what's the controls on this anyway?
C...
Z...
F...
C...
Q...
R...
S...
G...
Nothing.
Nothing works.
Wait, space?
Just a box.
Oh my god, just a present!
Just a present!
You can't punch kids.
Why can't I punch the child?
Why?
Are you gonna play Merry Gear Solid 2?
We'll see how I feel after this.
We'll see how I am after this, you know.
Oh my god.
Where's Santa Claus?
Mommy, does Santa exist?
Santa Claus!
How good is this kid's vision?
These dead kids!
Santa Claus!
I can't!
I can't with these children!
Santa Claus!
Oh my god.
We made it.
We made it, baby.
Oh, this is not a door we can go through.
We can only go upstairs.
We made it!
What is this?
Oh my god.
Wait, how do I...
Do you think I just run for it?
How many children are in this place?
How many kids do these people have?
How do I do this?
Just walk?
Santa Claus!
Mommy, does Santa exist?
Oh, it starts me at the second story though.
Ok, that's not so bad.
What if I knock?
Oh, I'm going to get discovered.
How am I supposed to do this?
How?
Ok.
So they can only see what's in front of them.
Ok, that's not so bad then.
Ok, ok.
Ok, ok, ok, ok.
Ok, ok, ok.
We got the gaps.
Yeah, straight line of sight.
It's not a cone.
It's not a cone like we are used to.
Fat air?
Thank you Amanda for the support.
Thank you Amanda!
Thanks for dropping by!
Amanda is one of the bosses.
One of the big bosses of MGSCon.
Which MGSCon is doing a Kickstarter.
Everybody, link in the description.
The boss, the boss.
The big boss.
Don't forget four sons spinning the hallways.
It's so funny.
Where should we...
I don't know where to knock.
Oh...
Where?
I don't want him to see me.
Where is the door?
Nice.
The third story.
East wing?
No...
I know there is no easy way past this one.
My Christmas spirit?
Telekinesis?
What?
What's the catch?
TV...
You know this is old because otherwise it would be like...
It would be like...
You just summoned TikTok or something.
What happens if I do it?
I was clicking OBS, my bad.
How long does it last?
I can't turn it off.
He did say that, didn't he?
I think I wasted it.
I think I wasted it because now I can't get past this.
I can't get past this one kid.
Oopsie!
Catch me kid!
It's too much.
Who made this?
Why?
For what reason?
OK.
Oh, I'm clicking the OBS again.
Oh my gosh.
Run!
What's this?
OK, it's just a little area to hide in.
Alright, we got the west wing everybody.
What?
Is this a present?
I got a gift!
Thank you for the hotdog!
Thank you so much!
Air holes?
No way!
Just a box!
Oh my gosh, we are going to be a present!
Are you guys feeling the Christmas spirit here?
Oh!
What?
It's just Christmas, you know.
It's just how it is, you know, Christmas stuff.
Just Christmas things, you know.
Oh my god, look how cute we are!
Try frequency... How do I get to codec?
I don't think I can just regularly codec them, can I?
OK.
Red light!
Green light!
Nice.
We are awesome.
We are so good at this game.
Shift!
He's not going to care.
He's not going to notice me.
OK.
Does he walk right...What if he walks on top of me?
He's not going to do that.
See guys!
Easy.
Oh no.
Wait, this looks like a room with lasers.
We'll come back.
I need the item over there.
I see.
What if I go through too?
What if I go through?
Santa!
Don't step there!
Wait, don't take another step.
You're going to set off an alarm.
Who are you?
Let's just say I'm your number one fan.
Call me Santa's Little Helper.
Santa's Little Helper?
How do I know I can believe what you're saying?
You don't have to believe anything, but if you want to get out of this mission unnoticed, you don't have much of a choice.
So maybe it's just best if you believe what I say.
Well, seeing is believing.
And I don't see any alarm systems here, so I don't believe a single thing you're saying either.
If you can only believe in the things that you can see, you're going to be a very unhappy man.
What do you mean?
Well, can you see gravity?
No.
Yes.
You mean we can kind of.
You wouldn't believe in it.
And if you don't believe in it, you'd be floating around.
But we can see things falling.
You said you don't believe in it, but you're not floating.
You're just being a hypocrite.
Nobody likes hypocrites.
Get called out, Santa.
And that's why you're going to be a very unhappy man.
I guess you're right.
I believe you.
This alarm system is set to go off if you touch its infrared laser meter.
Santa's a little helper.
I didn't know you were in the game.
So how am I supposed to get past it?
I'll let you figure that out by yourself.
No!
For someone named Santa's little helper, you sure don't help that much.
I'm a little helper.
I'm a big helper.
Oh god, we're gonna die to the kid.
Oh shoot.
What?
Wait.
I thought they could only see...
I thought they only saw what was right in front of them.
No way.
OK, interesting.
Santa Claus.
I think he hugs this wall, so I think we can go into the corner.
And we'll be fine.
Santa Claus.
What did we get?
Oh we got a candy cane?
Is that a sea cane?
We can ring their necks!
Read the wrapper.
But you're welcome to membership.
Thank you.
A what?
Seas candy.
No,
you have to believe Santa!
They think kids shouldn't believe in Santa.
Right!
OK.
Sorry, every time the codex ends I try to...
Oh wow, we're huffing and puffing.
I try to turn the music up and down.
Because it's so loud.
But the voices are kind of soft.
OK,
candy cane.
Candy cane.
Do these change?
No, it doesn't look like it.
Gosh, I'm so used to...
So used to other Metal Gears, right?
Doesn't Santa smoke a pipe?
Yeah, you're right!
He does!
Is that a little... What is this?
What's this on the floor?
Uh oh.
Why is there a pile of coals on the ground?
The ghost of Christmas Babble.
No way!
I said follow your footsteps, not follow in your footsteps, you idiot.
This is kind of... This is not a good dialogue.
They're funny.
They're pretty funny.
Wait, I think I need my huffer puffer.
OK.
Good thing this kid is not noticing any of the smoke.
Mommy!
Fire!
Stop, drop and roll!
OK.
We're gonna leave behind footprints.
And I know which way we need to go.
Does
the coal last?
How long does the coal last for?
Do you think he comes down?
OK, I'm gonna go for it.
Oh my god, this kid is still following me.
Kid!
Leave me alone, please!
TV!
I got something.
Oh my god, I'm blinding the children.
Oh.
Oh yeah, we're blinding the children!
OK.
Why?
Oh no!
Put them on the naughty list.
That's what we'll do with them.
We're gonna put them on the naughty list.
That's what we'll do.
I got a gun!
A Nerf gun!
Film, but it's digital.
Don't worry about it.
OK.
Oh no!
Oh perfect!
You're Santa!
Yeah,
kids.
You were supposed to be in bed.
OK, wait, so...
A Nerf Maverick REV6.
Hold down CTRL to look down the sights.
How did he save me?
Santa Claus!
Maybe I have to be fast.
Good night, children.
Santa Claus!
Oh, I bumped into him.
I guess that is how it happened, huh?
Oh my god!
There's so many kids!
Why are there so many kids?
And they're patrolling?
I see.
So, press CTRL to place on the ground.
Press again to take a photo.
The camera will automatically go off if an enemy gets too close.
OK.
Oh my god.
Oh, good thing I checked.
Good thing I checked.
Why are there so many children here?
How do I get through here, actually?
Do I have to... I think I have to put one of the kids to sleep.
And then go...
Wait, can they see past the trees?
Oh, I guess not.
Because I can... It looks like it acts like a wall, so...
OK.
CTRL...
Oh, SHIFT.
My bad.
SHIFT.
Gun.
I think we need to take out these kids.
How do I want to do this?
Oh, I think I know what I want to do.
I think I'm going to put a camera...
here.
And then... Oh, maybe that didn't work.
Wait, how long does this last?
Wait, hold on.
Wait.
Gun.
I might be in trouble.
Where are these presents under the tree?
These poor kids.
What are you talking about?
I'm trying to be... Send them Christmas cheer and they're...
OK.
I think I might have had the right idea.
Maybe.
I'm not quite sure.
OK.
Now, get my gun ready.
Now...
Wait.
Take this kid down?
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
And now I go.
No!
No way!
Oh my gosh.
Let's wait for these kids to come back through.
I don't know why it wasn't... tranquilizing the kids though.
Maybe we're thanks to the vibe gifted.
OK.
There we go.
Oh!
I see.
He turns around.
OK.
I'm going to present.
Tis the season.
Gotta ask.
How old were you when you found out that I saw Mommy kissing Santa Claus was about Daddy dressed as Santa Claus the whole time?
No.
If it was... If that were the case, it would be called I saw Mommy kissing my Dad dressed up as Santa Claus.
What are you talking about?
God, this kid can see?
OK.
I didn't realize he would see me from all the way down there too.
I thought I was far away enough, I'll be honest.
Yeah.
What you're talking about is... not real.
Oh gosh.
I messed up.
Fuck off.
I messed up everybody.
Oh wait, wrong way.
We made it?
We made it somehow?
OK, I'm a gift.
Oh what?
Oh my god.
Sometimes the kids can only see straight in front of them and sometimes it's a con.
Oh my gosh, how am I supposed to get this kid?
They wouldn't write a song about Santa NTR.
That's what...
Nerf him from afar?
I think I have to when he's turned around.
Oh, oh, oh!
I don't need to tranquilize them.
I can just walk right over them.
OK, turn around.
Nice.
Nighty night kid.
Alright.
Tell those kids to go to sleep or Santa will...
Santa will visit their mother and give her a kid she'll actually love.
Oh my god, Nilf!
Oh my god,
Nilf!
OK!
Nilf doesn't want to just...
Nilf wants to cause trauma to the children.
Oh my god.
Not just to put them on the naughty list.
I don't know.
Oh the...
Oh wait, I want to be here.
OK.
I'm just going for now.
I'm just... I don't know what I'm doing for now.
What?
These kids!
Oh my gosh, these kids are insane!
Don't you want to be a pretty good child on the nice list?
Yeah, right!
Wait!
Oh, I see kind of an issue here.
OK, hold on.
Let's test this.
OK, so they all look up.
OK.
Let me get caught now.
She won't get foxhound rank at this rate.
No, it would be reindeer rank.
But then there's the lasers here.
So I don't think I need to go around.
Right?
Hold on.
Candy can, that's right.
Yeah, there's lasers there, so going around would be kind of silly.
How do I do this part?
If I put a camera...
Oh, OK.
These kids have like 30-20 vision.
Funs against eagle-eyed kids.
When I was a kid, I had to get glasses.
I can't relate to these new...
Oh my god.
OK, it's right there.
I can't relate to these children that are...
That have this newfound vision.
Oh my god, only...
But how is that one kid able to see me?
This game, I can't.
OK, so that didn't work.
I like that it's kind of puzzly, you know?
Maybe I do... I guess I have to go around.
But...
I guess I have to go around.
Hug the wall near them?
Oh, and place it like that?
Let's see.
You cannot walk and hug the wall at the same time.
How long does the trank last?
I don't know, because they definitely get up.
OK, we'll wait for this kid.
Oh wait, this kid, we need to be a gift.
Nothing?
Santa Claus!
If I had moved he would have caught me anyway.
God, these kids.
Yeah, we'll definitely want to trank that guy.
This one I think is... I feel like I have to go really...
Really fast.
Like I have to distract them with a knock or something?
And then I have to go like...
Hello, fast, all the way back around or something.
I have to...
How do I do it?
Wait.
So I think I have to go around.
I have to trankolize all three of these kids.
On the left.
But then...
And then I use the TV and then I go through.
That's what I think I have to do.
Oh my gosh.
It's so...
Fast.
Stinking... This stinking kid up here.
Set up a flashbang.
Or I could do that.
Yeah, we could put the flashbang and then run by...
When they are like...
My eyes!
Oh wait.
No, wait.
How does that... Wait.
When I turn on the TV, all the kids will look up.
How do I run through?
My eyes!
Let's become a present.
I'm scared to move.
I can't see where he is.
Okay, there he is.
Does he go over anymore?
Okay.
So from here, we set up the D camera.
I'm a gift.
I'm a simple present.
I'm just a little guy.
Those are some tall kids.
Yeah, you're right.
Okay.
I'm still scared.
This kid.
Okay,
nice.
Nice and nice.
Nice and nice and nice and nice.
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Now...
D camera.
So while they are like...
Okay, they go...
We...
Press the TV.
We set up...
Another camera.
And we...
Have it go off.
Gosh, okay.
It didn't work!
It didn't work.
It was behind the wall.
How do I... There is no way for me to...
There is no way for me to...
I don't think I can knock anywhere.
I think I can only knock.
Let's see.
Maybe I can knock anywhere.
I swear I feel faster as a present.
Than as regular Santa.
Sorry, you can see my big ol' cursor.
Right up top.
Can you lower?
Lower the lower child.
I don't know.
Alright children, your eyes will go...
Knocked on the door just above the camera.
The one on the other side?
The one that I can't get to?
The one that...
Unless this...
The one I can't get to because there is lasers?
Happy Holidays Mito.
Happy Holidays!
If
I did that...
If I knocked on that door, the kids right there would turn around, would they not?
Get the lower kid to walk out from where he can see the camera.
Yeah, it's just...
It's just... Ooh, timing.
Timing.
OK.
Knock?
This
is the true final boss.
Santa Claus!
I'm glad this kid is blind at least.
It's this kid down here that I hate.
I hate this guy.
I hate this kid.
If I decamera...
If I do this...
And then knock...
I don't think there is much of a...
Just...
Trank all three, but they do wake up.
They wake up kind of fast.
Stage is kind of annoying because you got to loop every time to try the difficult part.
I just don't know the order of operations.
Test to see if the camera takes priority.
True.
They don't even hear it.
Do you think they are going to notice me?
Oh my god.
Do you think he is going to notice me?
No, this kid is blind.
I love this kid.
He causes me no stress.
I don't know the words.
I don't know the words to this song.
This part I swear...
It's got to be like probably some super crazy timing or something.
Huh...
Trank those three kids after you blind them to get more time to set up.
You think?
Let's try it.
Oh my gosh.
They ran to the damn laser!
I was just trying to turn sideways!
No!
I don't think you need to go all the way around.
Just knock to lure the three kids and hit them with the camera.
Let's try it.
I have no attachment to this run.
Hit them with the camera then knock them out again.
Or knock to lure the other two.
I
don't...I don't know.
We'll see.
Oh it's only the one.
I can't go any higher than that.
I can't go any higher.
Oh my god.
I blinded two.
Yeah, I blinded two, but how am I gonna get the...
The last...The one in the middle probably wouldn't notice me.
It's the one that's on the bottom that's the issue.
Dude!
Thanks for the raid!
Hi everybody!
We're playing Christmas Metal Gear.
OK, hold on.
Oh I can go...Wait.
I don't think...
Let's see.
So I can only go up to here.
Let me take them out.
Say goodnight kid.
Oh that's the camera!
Anyway...
That kid up there sees me!
OK, wait.
OK, hold on.
Because also I can go up here.
Maybe if I go up here and knock it would be better.
OK, I'm gonna leave the camera here.
I'm gonna go up here and we're gonna knock here.
Oh!
I killed all three of them!
Nice, nice, nice, nice!
Please!
No!
I keep switching to the camera!
Wait, I can't get the last kid.
Maybe I can.
I think I missed my chance.
OK, so that's what I have to...Oh my god, they're awake for such a little amount of time.
OK, that's what I gotta do.
OK, we know what we gotta do.
Then TV...OK, OK, OK.
OK, OK.
I just gotta not mess it up.
Switch to camera.
Then switch to gun.
TV, TV, TV!
The
Christmas tree!
Can I leave?
Wait.
We made it!
Good.
Now get out of there.
Are you kidding me?
Now I have to do it backwards.
Yes, I have to artificially extend playtime somehow.
No way!
Oh, wow, excuse me.
I don't know what got into me.
Anyway, good luck.
Wait, there is a chimney right there!
No way!
The chimney!
The chimney Santa!
No way!
Wait, what?
USB tactical fitted with a suppressor.
The ideal choice for a stealth mission.
Aim it at someone's back to hold them up.
Wait, why can't I hold it?
Freeze!
Actual solid steak!
Oh my god, we got double crossed.
I was sent on a mission to assassinate his twin brother, Bigbeard.
You, see, you were part of the Los Bigotes Perfectos Project.
The Los Bigotes Perfectos Project?
Yeah, the Los Bigotes Perfectos Project.
It was a top secret project started by Andrew Johnson back in the 19th century.
President Johnson was quite displeased with his lack of facial hair.
Especially after the abundant beard of his predecessor, Abraham Lincoln.
His wife started funding research on bioengineering with a perfect beard.
The research resulted in the birth of twin clones.
Los Bigotes Perfectos.
One of the twins received the genes for the perfect beard.
And this twin became known as Bigbeard.
But for Bigbeard to be created, you needed to be another twin to whom all this has changed for a good while.
Bigbeard is like also a... also a sibling.
If we have Bigbeard and Bigboss, then we also have Bigbird.
Oh my god.
Ooterheaven.
It's cut off.
Metal Gear!
Wait, no!
This is Mary Gear!
Bigbird leaves the Aerial Division.
Bigbeard!
No!
Oh, he's so... OK.
He's so fine with it.
Oh my god, no!
Santa!
Secret Santa!
He killed Santa.
Oh my god.
Major Tim.
Solid...
What?
What is that?
After Santa Bar?
Thanks to Hideo Kojima.
How does this man's name still get put into the game?
Even though he has nothing to do with it.
Bravo, Kojimba.
What?
The SA goods?
Like something awful?
Oh no!
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
That's me.
I've made a grave mistake.
Did we get the wrong guy?
There is multiple people going and infiltrating houses.
Mammoth.
Does that mean I'm slow?
OK, we get it.
We get it.
Can we sing that song in the next karaoke?
I think I'm good.
Time taken.
That's a lot of seconds.
Times discovered, 22.
Well, there is a second game, but isn't the second... OK, so...
I saw that the first game, this one... I only saw like Vinny play it.
And it was like 30 minutes or 40 minutes that he took.
And then he played it again and it was like...
It was like 3 hours.
It was really long.
So I'm like, wait a second.
It's longer though.
Big hairy Minto with tusks is so cute.
So I'm not sure if I'm up for like a 3 hour adventure.
From what we just did.
All these kids look the same.
I assume they are clothes.
Johan!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
What do we want to do?
The genome kids.
Maybe for real Christmas?
We could do that, like on Christmas Eve.
I was wondering what I wanted to do that week.
So, maybe...
Watching your streams and hearing you sing gave me karaoke confidence and I sang Snow Halation at a public karaoke last night.
Oh my gosh, Aeon, let's go!
But everyone was just like, wow.
Deliver it.
Hope Salazana gives me Ace Combat 8.
I hope for you too.
But I don't want to end stream, it's only been an hour.
What do?
I guess I could just talk.
We could just hang out.
My computer is all messed up though.
Did we beat the game?
We beat the game!
No alert run?
OK, let's try it.
How do I skip the codex?
We are speedrunning!
Skip, skip, skip!
Oh I got it, nice.
I'm a genius.
Skip-a, skip-a, skip-a, skip-a.
Oh gosh, it scares me.
Oh my gosh!
We almost didn't make that you guys, but we made it!
First floor!
Down!
Climb the ladder again.
What a thrill.
Oh wait, I'm an idiot!
Guys, I'm stupid.
I'm dumb.
I was looking at the kid below.
Instead of the kid, the run is over at the second floor!
We know Minky, it's OK.
Diddly diddly diddly diddly did.
OK, we gotta wait for this kid too.
OK, we are a genius at this part now.
We are so good.
Third time's the charm.
I don't know, I think I'm gonna get caught again.
I got caught so many times before.
OK.
OK, alright.
OK, nice.
What was that?
These kids voices are so funny.
I wish it was that I could get caught sometimes.
I wish I could get caught like...
Like one time on each floor, you know?
Once on each floor, you know?
That's what I wish.
Potentially get caught.
How about zero times?
No, I'm trying, I'm trying.
I'm trying, but I'm scared.
If I lose here, it's all over.
So far.
Maybe.
Oh, this kid comes down, I remember.
OK, I'm gonna stay right here.
OK, alright.
Now we wait...
What if I get caught only one time on each floor?
What if I get caught only one time...
That kid wasn't supposed to turn around!
This bastard!
Bastard!
Solid 2 is more elaborate.
People have been begging me to play these games.
OK.
Oh my god, he turns around immediately.
This kid sucks.
You're getting coal for the rest of your life.
Little Timmy.
What an asshole.
Ranked terrible, still cute though.
Shut up!
No, not Mammoth!
If we get anything other than Mammoth, I think that's kind of a win.
I'm being extra cautious.
I don't want the Mammoth.
We are speedrunning!
I might get like cheetah for how fast we are.
They'll be like, whoa!
Speed!
Cheetah!
You're the fastest.
So speedy.
Oh.
Wait, why are you calling me?
Hey!
Shut up Santa's little helper.
You're slowing down my playtime.
Oh my gosh, that was close.
Can you imagine if I accidentally ran into a laser?
That'd be silly.
That'd be silliness.
Guys, we can do this.
Maybe.
Oh, the coal.
That's right.
OK.
Oh wait, I think... OK.
OK, that's right.
We step in the coal.
OK.
I can't waste too much time because...
OK, go, go, go!
Who is that?
Nobody?
No one?
Not a single person?
Nobody?
Are you kidding me right now?
I think I paused there before thinking that the kid was going to...
Wow.
I'm so...
I think... I was thinking the kid would do something else when I first played.
That's why I didn't know I could get caught if I just didn't stop.
But you have to stop there.
But I don't know for how long.
OK.
I know for how long.
Wow!
This game is... Wow!
It's really trying to kill me, huh?
Yeah, you paused before.
I did!
It's OK.
We only got caught two times, guys.
Surely...
Surely everything is fine.
Oh, I got a gun now.
I got the gun.
The Nerf gun.
OK.
Nighty night, kid.
Nighty night, kid, too.
OK.
Shoot them kids.
They're going downtown.
We only got discovered three times.
We only got discovered three times now, guys.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, I put another one down on accident.
Oh wait, that's right.
I can just walk past them.
This kid, though, he has no fear.
Alright, next time.
Wait.
Oh, OK.
Next time.
Turn around.
OK.
My bullet was in mid!
No!
These kids, literal...
This is what I meant to do.
OK, there we go.
OK, we didn't mess up.
Oh, I did mess up.
It's fine.
Wait.
OK, anyway.
Back on track.
OK, turn around.
Turn around.
Got him.
Little bastard.
Cool for you.
Cool.
Naughty.
Naughty, naughty, naughty.
Naughty child.
Naughty boy.
TV.
Run, run, run, run, run.
First try!
Yeah!
Oh, I accidentally left a present.
Freeze.
Speedrun.
I can speedrun a little bit.
What was my speed?
I don't care about the credits anymore, please.
Please let me out.
It's kind of difficult because I'm looking at the window projector.
But then I have to go back to my tiny screen.
Oops, sorry.
I have to go back to my tiny screen to press stuff.
This entire song is just peaking.
What an amazing first run.
I'm just too good at this game.
Louder?
Do you want me to put it at what I normally have my music at?
I don't think you want that.
I'm dancing.
What do you think my rank is, you guys?
I wanted to get Fox Santa.
Foxy Santa.
But he's probably already Foxy.
Terrible!
You're right.
Terrible.
What is it?
What could it be?
Oh wait, can I skip this part too?
No, I can't.
Big beard.
Nice putty!
No, sir.
Yes, sir.
Thinking zebra.
What would zebra mean?
Literally just left to heat up leftovers and she beat the game again already.
I'm too good!
I'm too good at this game.
There is actually a sequel.
I do know.
We might not play it today, but that's OK.
Let's see.
What did I get?
I'll never escape.
I'll never escape the allegations.
Is it the ears?
Ranking.
Elf.
Stop.
Well, even better.
You know what?
It was worth replaying, huh?
For this, right?
It was worth replaying for this, huh?
I guess.
Maybe.
Goodness, how silly.
It was worth.
You have the ears for... Oh wait, I have to go to the left to go to the right?
Elf.
Take the elf, Minto.
Elf on the shelf.
Oh my gosh, I've been watching a bunch of elf on the shelf videos.
Because people are so funny with how creative they get with them, you know?
Like they'll be like...
They'll be like...
Sometimes some people will put string on their elf, so when the kids walk into the room it looks like the elf is moving.
And then they'll make it look like the elf was like...
Oh no, I got caught.
And like drop the strings, you know?
And the kid will be like, my elf was moving!
And Rainbow, thank you for joining.
Welcome, thank you.
Are you skipping elf practice?
My mom used to get super creative with it for my younger brother, it was really sweet.
Yeah, it looks fun.
Looks fun.
Anyway, let's see.
Hot dog.
Elf minto would be cute too.
I can't be a ghost elf.
I think that's too many layers.
Right?
I can't be a maid and a ghost and an elf.
I have to be only, like you know, I have to be...
Ghost maid or ghost elf.
I can't be both.
Oh, sorry.
You could submit this run on speedrun.
Why could I?
Elf minto never beating the alligators.
I guess, you guys just want to hang out and talk until...
For just a bit.
I know that...
I know there is a sequel, but I don't feel like quite doing it today.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm sorry.
Okay, let me go to the bathroom first and then we'll just hang out.
You guys can listen to the song for a bit.
Okay, hold on.
I'll be right back.
I'm going to turn off Amerigear.
Oh wait, let me do this first.
There we go.
Goodbye Amerigear.
Goodbye, goodbye.
Let's go... Okay, hold on.
Let's go to... Oh wait, hold on.
I have to go to the right, to go to the left, to go to the right, to go to the left.
And then we'll go to here.
And then we'll do this, and then we'll do that.
Okay,
I have to get rid of that.
Dang it!
It ruined all my stuff!
I've been having so many issues with my... As I told you, I've been having so many issues with my monitors.
And it keeps ruining my OBS settings every time!
It's so frustrating, actually.
So frustrating, actually.
And then also my... I'm all messed up too.
Okay, maybe that.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to make it a little bigger.
And I'm gonna... We don't need the eye patch anymore, I suppose.
What happened?
If you didn't see, that's okay.
It's better that way.
If you don't see.
Wait.
No,
don't say what it was!
Stop it!
Stop!
Don't ruin the illusion!
Are you sure they're both plugged directly into your GPU ports?
I've had issues with that before.
They should be.
I'll check after, though.
Stop.
This is the Wizard of Oz.
There you go, thanks for the five gifted.
Did you have fun?
I did!
That was actually so good.
I feel like most of the levels were... I don't want to say too easy.
I liked the last level.
I wish there was more of ones like the last one.
That were more puzzly, you know?
So I'll head for the concert next weekend.
It's going to be my first trip to Atlanta.
Wow, let's go!
Um...
Things to do in Atlanta.
Waffle House.
I told Doki we should go to Waffle House.
I was like, what do we do while we're there?
Waffle House.
The elusive Waffle House.
Don't go to the downtown one.
Why?
Is it bad?
Wait, isn't it good if it's bad, though?
Wouldn't it be better for it to be bad?
Wouldn't it be better if it's a PvP zone?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, my computer is all messed up.
My computer is all messed up.
Good luck with the concert.
Thanks!
Become a vampire ghost.
No.
Waffle House fights are the best.
It's not a Waffle House, it's a Waffle Home.
Cabo, thank you.
Yeah, I'm trying to take it a little bit easy this week in terms of stream lengths.
So, even though tomorrow I want to play Indiana Jones...
But I was like...
The aquarium is really good.
Really?
Wait, it's the biggest in the US?
What?
Okay.
Noted.
Have fun at the Atlanta Ferris Wheel.
There's a Ferris Wheel?
Like just... What makes it the Atlanta Ferris Wheel?
Sister, they got a whale shark.
Oh my god!
I love whale sharks.
Okay, I got a message, Doki.
We're going to the aquarium.
Oh my god!
Because it's Atlanta.
It's in Atlanta.
I thought it would be like in the shape of a peach or something.
They should theme it.
If it's in Georgia.
They should theme it as a peach, right?
Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine going on a Ferris Wheel and being like...
This is the butt wheel.
You can also tour the Coca-Cola factory?
It wouldn't be a wheel then, would it?
I don't know what kind of buttocks you were looking at, but I'm always looking at a nice round...
It's round.
I'll see you at Ofuka?
Yeah!
Gonna need more Ace Combat merch.
Tour the Coke factory and taste sodas from all over the world.
Most of them are horrible.
Wait...
A nice round thing.
An itty bitty waist and a big round thing in your face, you get sprung.
In the Ferris Wheel, son.
Oh yeah, I don't think I would want to go to the Coca-Cola place though, because...
I can't have soda.
So it's like...
Don't believe them?
The world of Coke is not worth all.
Yeah, I can't have soda, so it's like...
I wouldn't be able to drink anything.
Pika!
Welcome to Bubble Ship!
Thank you.
The Coke place is right by the aquarium.
Double feature.
Do you think we could go to both in a day?
Or is the aquarium too big?
A lot of people do.
The Coke thing is super short.
Maybe Doki would like it.
I can't have soda, but Doki might like it.
Stick to the aquarium.
Go to Legoland?
Legoland?
There's Legoland?
I know that there's the Six Flags in Georgia.
I'm new here, thanks to Doki Bird.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
Is... Do you think there would be... Wait, is the Six Flags... Wait, for people that know...
Is there Six Flags... No, sorry.
Is the Six Flags close?
Or is it like a Disney situation where it's far?
There's a Lego Discovery Center.
What?
It's not close.
It's closed?
Oh.
What?
It's closed?
What happened?
It's closed for the season?
They don't do... They don't do...
Like, winter stuff?
Like Disney does?
It's one hour... Oh, one hour out of Atlanta is closed for the season.
No!
No, I wanted to ride!
I figured though that probably we wouldn't have time and it would be kind of bad actually to like...
Can you imagine I go on a rollercoaster and I'm like...
And then at the concert I'm like, hey guys, I can't talk.
Hey guys, I lost my voice at Six Flags.
But that might happen if I go to the aquarium too.
I'm just like...
I wonder if we could go...
We'll have to see our schedule.
I don't really know...
We'll have two Dokis on stage.
Hey guys, I'm Doki Bird.
Do you scream at the fish?
You don't?
You don't get so excited over seeing the fish?
I don't know what our schedule is like yet.
I don't know.
I actually don't know when Doki gets in, so...
We haven't made any plans at all.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe it's this weekend.
It's this weekend.
Scary.
I'm so nervous.
I wanna also check out the convention too.
I wanna haunt it a little bit if we have time.
There's too much to do now, huh?
We gotta go to the convention, we gotta go to the Coca-Cola, we gotta go to the aquarium.
We gotta go to the Ferris wheel, but not...
Wait, so the Ferris wheel...
It's just a Ferris wheel.
It's not like at a theme park?
Atlanta is a big city.
What food would you recommend for anybody that knows?
Food, food, food.
Food, food.
I'm thinking Waffle House.
I'm thinking...
Wagaya.
Soul food.
The Atlanta Botanical Garden has a beautiful Christmas light display at night.
Be prepared to walk though.
Oh my gosh, I would love to go to a garden.
That sounds so nice.
Minto, is that one girl from Finding Nemo?
I'm a piranha.
That's like how you... That's the one thing you always ask though when you're going to a place, right?
What do you get... What do you get to eat?
I remember when Zun went to AWA a while back.
They put Tenchi on the official con t-shirt because of peaches.
Because of the peaches on her hat, right?
That's such a...
That's such a random character.
That's so random.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches.
Vortex is great.
The varsity is not worth the trip.
It's basic burgers and fries.
Not terrible.
You could get it anywhere.
Noted.
The Vortex.
Vortex and Fox Bros Barbecue.
I want some barbecue!
Oh yeah!
And for those who can't make it to the...
To the... To the concert...
Hopefully...
We can just have another concert, right?
I imagine this is not going to be mine nor Doki's last concert, so...
There's this place called McDonald's?
Wait...
Master?
Master McDonald?
Wisps are flying Krisu out.
And he'll try to get a recording up.
Yes!
Krisu!
You guys are flying him out.
There's a super good barbecue place named Woods Chapel near the concert venue.
Fox Bros is also really good.
Okay, I need to write these down.
Fox Bros?
Wait, Fox Bros?
Fox Hound?
I might have to go to Fox Bros because...
My brain rot.
And what was the other one?
Woods Chapel.
And then you guys said...
Vortex.
Not the Varsity.
When are we opening Minto's maxi buns?
The Vortex.
Take pics, please, if food.
I will try.
I'm not usually so good about taking pictures of my food.
But I'll try.
I'll try, I'll try.
Hot dog.
You.
You're from the North Pole.
There's nothing there but snow drifts and sweet gifts.
And you don't look cold and powdery to me.
So that just about narrows it down.
What is this referencing?
Just a reminder since another user let me know.
If you order the VIP package, the message closes tomorrow.
Check your spam folders.
Check, check, check.
He reminded me.
I need to do some stuff.
There's still so much to do.
Taking a bunch of plane figures on Bayi.
I looked up that art book.
He told me about it.
I looked it up on Mercari.
JP.
And I saw one and then it got sold out.
But there was another one.
There was a couple on there.
I haven't bought it yet.
Oh, full metal jacket.
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes.
Bayi, they're great.
Yeah, they're very helpful.
Very helpful, right?
Especially because I get a lot of stuff on Mercari Japan.
Maybe too much stuff.
I basically check everyday.
I basically check everyday for Metal Gear things.
I still have to... I got the mats, the floor mats that they recently released.
And the pillows.
I haven't bought the little jiggly plushies yet.
I gotta get those too.
I use Bayi for booth.
See, I use Tenso for booth.
I had a Tenso account before I had a Bayi account.
And so, all my booth stuff goes through Tenso.
Which is the same company.
They're getting my money.
They get a lot of my money.
I got one from Bayi.
Guess I was lucky.
Nice!
Check Ebay.
Oh, yeah.
Well, because you mentioned the ones that were in Japanese.
And of course, since it was Mercari Japan, it's in Japanese.
But I would like to get an English one.
What's the difference?
So Tenso...
Okay, so Bayi...
Yeah, Bayi...
Works for specific sites like Mercari and Yahoo Auctions.
But Tenso...
Basically, you send them the item and they buy it for you.
But Tenso gives you your own address.
So you can purchase things directly from the website.
C.O.D.
Yeah, Tenso is just forwarding.
I stopped using Tenso because they don't do C.O.D.
What is that?
C.O.D.
What's that?
Call of Duty?
Oh, cash on delivery.
What's...
What circumstance would you...
Need that?
Like if you were trying to...
Pay...
For...
When you have to pay duties.
Are you feeling better from yesterday?
I was gonna make a CPR joke, but my cringe sensor is on.
I am feeling better, thank you.
Yeah, I'm sorry again, I didn't really want to bring it up.
But if you saw...
The...
What's the word?
Devil May Cry 3 stream.
I wasn't feeling very well yesterday.
Basically...
I was like...
I was having a bad day.
And then I didn't have time to eat.
But I also had no appetite to eat.
Because I was so...
I've been a little...
I don't know.
I've been a little brain broke recently.
And I...
Got over my chair and I...
I don't know.
I don't want to describe it in such a detail.
Or anything.
But essentially, I like...
Got really dizzy.
And then I like...
Had like a panic attack.
I was like, I think I should leave.
So...
You know.
But I'm feeling better today.
Sorry, again, about it.
But it's okay.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Thank you.
Until my first...
Vtuber concert yesterday.
I usually don't dance, but...
Thanks.
I dance so much.
Let's go!
Sounds so fun.
Oh my gosh, I was watching the...
I didn't get tickets for it.
But I was watching like the freebie streaming...
Of Marine's concert.
And...
Oh my gosh, the stage was so cool!
It was like in the shape of a boat!
It was so awesome.
Yeah, our new model.
The one with the horns?
Oh my god.
I missed it.
I think it's still...
You can still watch the free hour.
It was so cool.
Like I said, I didn't get the full thing.
But...
Did you see the streamer awards?
Oh!
I didn't watch, but I saw...
Mousy's concert.
Oh my gosh.
Like her...
Her 3D thing.
I guess you call it a concert, right?
Her 3D...
Show?
It was so awesome too!
There was so much going on.
Yeah.
I don't typically watch...
Awards.
Her 3D performance.
Yeah!
It was so good.
It was so, so good.
I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I was really happy for her.
I thought...
I saw that...
I saw a lot of people were there.
Like Gigi was there.
Doki was there.
Mousy was there.
I think it's cool what they're doing.
Right!
I'm glad that...
It seems that more...
More people are...
How do I say?
Not accepting, but are more...
Knowing about Vtubers.
Uh...
Doki was there in spirit.
I thought she was actually...
There there.
Or not like...
You know.
I thought I saw her on the iPad.
Recognizing.
Yeah.
Aware of open to Vtubers, right?
She was streaming...
Did she just...
Think that she didn't win?
What did she want?
She was a wallpaper on the iPad?
What?
She was going to pause it.
Oh my god.
Did she finally beat Silent Hill 2?
She would have had Gumi put her on call.
Oh, she did beat it.
I wonder if she like...
Did she like it?
Silent Hill 2...
She got the best ending?
I think she had mixed feelings.
Like is a strong word.
She got the best ending despite what her chat was shouting at her.
That's pretty typical, right?
She checked the map 644 times.
It counts?
How many times did you check the map?
I still haven't played the remake.
I know it got really great reviews.
I feel like...
So many games have come out that people have been like...
Kind of like...
I'm not sure how this is going to be.
And so many games have come out that exceeded people's expectations.
I'm really happy about that.
I don't have any plans on streaming it.
I played Silent Hill 2, the original.
But...
It's a bit too combat heavy, IMO.
I've heard that...
I've heard that complaint about it.
How you go into a room and there's basically a mannequin in every single room.
Like you go into a room and you prepare for the combat.
Streaming the Game Awards?
When is that?
When are the Game Awards?
Game Awards...
Oh, sorry.
My window...
Oh, my computer's all borked.
Game Awards...
2024.
The twel...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
No!
I can't!
I cannot.
No!
I will just think about Astro Bot.
As an OG Silent Hill 2 fan...
I started it last week.
It's definitely combat heavy.
But it keeps the game tense in a different way.
I didn't dislike it at all.
That's fair.
No, I think...
I think different is good too.
It's kind of also like a lot of people...
I know it hasn't come out yet, but Delta...
People have been very like...
I don't think so, but...
A lot of people trying it at Tokyo Game Show and everything...
Have been like...
Yeah, baby, this is the good stuff.
Me included.
I'm very optimistic.
And I know...
I know it's hard...
It's way easier to be jaded about stuff...
When there's been many letdowns.
But I think it's fun to be optimistic about things...
And wanting to like things, you know?
I think it's good to be...
You know...
Like excited for stuff.
If only I could get a PS5.
For...
Astro Bot?
Or for Delta, because Delta is not just gonna be...
Not just PS5.
Unlike what I thought.
But I got Astro Bot, so honestly...
I don't regret my PS5 purchase.
Astro Bot and Delta.
I wonder...
I wonder if I should play Delta on my PS5.
I don't know, I haven't thought...
I haven't decided yet.
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Fiveever and Lofilesbian.
Thank you guys!
Welcome, welcome.
No mods on PS5 though.
True.
Very, very true.
I played...
I played MGSV on console.
So I didn't get any of the mods.
And I wanted to change the music.
You know how you can like set custom music for P-Quad.
Seems like they're actually trying with Delta.
Especially after the negative reception MGS collection got.
Yeah!
I think they have listened very much to their fans.
Or rather to people's criticisms.
Which is good.
They haven't shied away from it at all.
Did you see Platypus getting a remaster?
Platypus?
Ever since you told them dragoons have been feminizing each other and won't stop.
This is your fault and I hope you're happy with the chaos you've caused.
I...
I thought Doki said...
Oh she was like I'm gonna nip that in the bud.
They won't.
They won't do that.
That's not my fault.
That's Doki's fault.
If you ever want to play Fortnite you should invite Doki.
Epic gave her the ability to create custom battle royale lobbies to play with fans.
Oh really?
Interesting.
Really?
That's so gross.
Where exactly?
Yeah.
Can we please direct Fukigan to the...
To the...
To the photos.
For evidence.
For...
For evidence that we can use...
To...
Learn about the enemy's weakness.
And how we can take him down.
Hold on.
What would he do?
He would just...
He would...
He would encounter an enemy and literally he would auto run away.
He would auto escape.
People are saying Miku.
I saw that.
I saw a tweet actually that was saying...
Miku is going to be in Fortnite.
What?
Fortnite might actually be the most powerful game of all time.
It's kind of insane.
Now...
Have they gotten like any...
Like Final Fantasy characters?
This reminds me...
Marry me, Minto.
What do you mean?
What reminds you?
No Final Fantasy yet.
Not even Caitlyn?
I miss Caitlyn.
Meeting Cait-Syn?
Stop it!
I miss him!
Having Tifa and...
Tifa...
Did I say Tifa?
Having Tifa and Aerith would be great though.
I'll go nuts if they add Sora.
Have they added any Square Enix characters?
Come on, they gotta...
Those are the negotiations.
They gotta work on.
They have Snake in Fortnite though.
I know.
I have him.
Tifa.
She's all toothy.
Fortnite Snake stream.
I got him.
I need to use him, right?
I'm sad I couldn't get Raiden and Old Snake though.
Because I couldn't play much.
It was...
Snake came out right before I was leaving for Japan.
So like...
It was a bad timing for me.
Earlier this year.
Raiden comes back every so often but...
Old Snake!
But Old Snake!
Snake!
I thought you said you got Old Snake.
No, I don't think so.
I don't think so.
Sad.
So sad.
Sadly, Fortnite doesn't have Snakes but...
That is true.
Yeah, it's Disney which is powerful.
True, true.
I think the Disney stuff is so funny and how they're like...
How they're like...
Oh yeah, some of our Disney characters, they don't have weapons.
Like, you know what game you were putting them in.
You know that...
You know that Fortnite is a shooty game.
If you didn't want your characters to shoot...
Why would you...
Why would you put them in?
Silliness.
The season is Baymax.
Cute!
Cute.
I never got Goku either.
I was so sad.
Do you know Ace Combat series?
The composer is the same one that does the music for Idolmaster in the latest Final Fantasy 7 remake.
Really?
The music in Final Fantasy 7 remake is so...
It's so beautiful.
I love the many many arrangements of...
I love Tifa's theme and Aerith's theme and I love how many arrangements there were.
No Goku.
Goku, Goku, Goku.
Snakes don't belong in Tomato Town.
Vtubers in Fortnite win?
I can 100% see...
Ironmouse or Gura...
Getting in Fortnite.
I can 100% see either of them.
Why not Doki?
I can see her too.
But you know how it's like...
When people think of the big...
The biggest...
The big big biggies...
Of Vtubing...
In the West.
It's Ironmouse and Gura, you know?
Why not Minto?
I think I'm okay.
No, if I got the offer to be put in Fortnite...
I think that is one offer I would accept.
Some other things...
I have declined.
Because...
I've been like...
I...
Don't want this for myself.
So I would not want others to...
I am not so money hungry to accept everything.
So...
Some offers I have been like...
Thank you for the offer!
But I think I'm good.
Are you allowed to say what?
I will not say exactly...
But...
Certain...
Companies that make figurines...
And such...
So...
I've been kind of like...
I don't...
I don't want it, so...
You guys are not guessing correctly.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
I don't know.
I don't really like those...
The ones that are like...
You know, not to knock anybody else who gets them, obviously.
If they get them, like...
That's totally fine.
But like the...
The companies that like...
Have their like standardized...
Faces or...
Like the...
Figures all look the same.
Either with the same face or like the same...
Body or something.
I'm not a huge fan.
So...
I was just like...
I think I'm good.
But...
Hopefully one day I can get a Nendoroid.
Hopefully one day I can get a Nendoroid or...
I don't really collect Nendoroids.
I really want...
If I could have the option, I would really want a...
Pop-up parade, I think.
I would really want a pop-up parade.
One that's like a...
Not a scale figure, but almost, right?
I love pop-up parades.
They're so...
They're such...
They're such nice quality for the price point.
I'm like, thank goodness these exist.
And they have so many...
So many different people.
Are you going to get the Kiwawa Nendo?
See...
I'm conflicted, because like I said, I don't...
I don't think I...
Actually, no.
I have some Nendoroids, but they're very old ones.
I haven't bought a Nendoroid in a really long time.
I'm so glad that it finally came out.
I think I'll probably get it, just because it's Kiwawa, you know?
I felt so bad for her.
I was like, please, release the Wawa.
Release the Wawa.
Figma?
I don't really collect Figma.
I'm such a scale figure snob, I'm sorry.
I...
I don't really collect Figmas either.
I did get those snake Nendoroids.
The snake at the right Nendoroid.
I did get those.
Minto is an elitist.
When you get your own Nendo, you can make them kiss.
If...
If I get my own, you know.
When is the master grade Minto kit?
No Venom Nendo?
They didn't re-release it.
They only re-released the...
But I don't think I would get a Venom one.
Yeah, I don't think I would.
Venom is just kind of...
To me.
Minto Nen would be 1 to 1 scale.
Shut up!
No!
Why do you guys think I'm so small?
This is messed up.
Small Minky.
Doki's Nendoroid looks so great though.
She just had the...
The colored pictures come out recently.
I like how she has so many accessories.
Like it kind of...
Almost looks like...
Because you can add Kroaky and the tomato.
Like it looks really full.
I like it a lot.
Smaller than JPEG.
No!
I'm 149 centimeters!
A perfectly replicated smug.
Yeah!
Would yours come with Frogbert?
I don't know.
I don't know what I would get for accessories.
Well, I would have to get a Wisp, right?
I would want one of you guys crying.
149 millimeters.
No!
Eyepatch.
True.
Maybe a box too.
A cardboard box.
Well, I don't know.
Maybe I wouldn't want to choose that as my accessory.
Unless I can like...
Unless...
Because you can always make your own.
You heard her.
She's 1.49 centimeters.
No!
My dog...
JPEG dog cutout is bigger.
You have a cutout of the JPEG dog?
Just a box.
Small copy of Metal Gear.
What expressions would you guys want?
What expressions?
Maybe like a wink?
Mint is like grandma's homemade food.
Puts a smile on your face.
Full of love.
Everyone likes it.
And don't forget...
She's spicy.
I do 555...
Oh my god, why is it so big?
That's too big for a dog!
Disgusted face?
What, like...
Like this one?
Heart pupils?
I don't even have those.
I don't even have those!
Disgusted, disappointed face.
You guys are such freaks.
The cat eyes.
That would be good too, right?
Makes me wish that they...
Actually, if they ever have a Koharu Nendoroid...
Nendoroid, you can just swap the face.
You can just be like...
You can just swap it!
Execution.
Death penalty.
Bandana, eyepatch, tranquil and cardboard box.
Minifigure of snake.
Gehe, Ojiisan face.
That's just my normal.
I don't know.
I have lots of time to think about it, I suppose.
When I was talking to someone earlier, I was like...
I was like, I'm always thinking of stuff.
But then when it comes time to actually like...
Be like, okay.
Think of something and we'll do it.
I'm like...
Like I've been thinking of...
Next merch?
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed!
Your chibi model is literally like 90% Nendo.
True!
Thank you for the great stream.
It was a great way to end the week.
Thank you, Kuya!
Show the JPEG dog later after stream.
Okay, good.
I wanna see it.
You should bring it to Half-Kai.
Next merch.
I know, right?
Already thinking.
I want you guys to get the plushie first though.
Chibi Minto Nendo.
I would have to ask...
The artist of Chibi Minto...
If they would be okay with...
Turning...
With using their art though, you know?
Obviously, I feel Ayami Mama would be okay.
But...
For Chibi Minto, might be different.
Amuri!
Happy birthday, Amuri!
Happy birthday!
Myakama!
Hello, hello, hello!
Alright, Mac.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Everybody say happy birthday to Amuri.
Hello!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thanks for the gifted!
We're the Dayon Burais and we're here to make your day jolly.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Hope you had fun.
You looked so sexy in your...
Towel.
Gonna be in the replies.
Okay, I'll look for it.
Audio!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Phantom!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
The birthday outfit, yeah.
Everybody should go see Amuri's...
Amuri's...
Shopkeeper, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys for all the gifted.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, Amuri's, large Amuri's.
Yeah.
Sorry, if you're just like...
Ah, Minto, I need...
I need a little bit of fan service here.
Minto!
Minto, please!
Give me anything, Minto!
If you need something like that to satisfy you.
It's okay, I understand.
You
mean very nice.
Stop!
Thigh is next.
But I'm standing.
You know what fan service you could give me.
Actually, I don't...
Orca, I don't...
I'm scared.
I'm scared what you mean by that.
Here, I'll do...
I'll back away from your table.
There we go.
I love my washboard.
Wait!
Don't say a washboard!
Wiggle, wiggle.
Yellow middle.
That's the best of what you are.
I love your eggs.
White and tender.
Surround the center.
Cozy, sitting in their crackling shells.
I love you!
Be careful when ordering from Good Smile website.
Oh yeah!
I think they got something up with it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That is justice.
It's a status symbol.
But yeah, be careful.
I don't know if it's fixed.
Yeah, I don't know.
Good Smile US in particular.
Vitamins and minerals in you.
Oodles of the proteins too.
Oodles, doodles.
Wait, let me look up the lyrics.
Eggs.
Egg song.
What?
Eggs.
Get your eggs here.
Fresh and white eggs are here.
Wiggle, jiggle.
Yellow middle.
That's the best of what you are.
Wait, vitamins.
Wait.
Oodles.
Popular and perfect and so complete in every way.
I love you egg, egg.
Come into my tummy.
Oh, so very yummy.
Crack, crack, crack.
Chip a chip away your shell and come to me.
Get your eggs.
I love you fresh egg.
I love you white eggs.
Really, really love you.
So eggs, fresh, fresh eggs.
Eggs, I really love you.
Like the sky above.
Eggs are the best.
I love you fresh egg.
I love you white egg.
Really, really love you.
So eggs, fresh, fresh eggs.
365 days.
I really love you so.
Yummy.
Egg song.
What a flashback.
There's a Korean version too.
Oh wait, I think I know that actually.
I think I knew that.
Heard you're strong Mint.
I am strong.
Remember the milk and cereal song.
No, I don't know that one.
You know another song I sing a lot though from that era is...
The Magical Trevor.
Everybody loves Magical Trevor.
Cause the tricks that he does are ever so clever.
Look at him now, disappearing the cow.
Where is the cow?
Hidden right now.
Taking a bow is Magical Trevor.
I don't remember.
And then...
I still like...
There's the other one that I sometimes sing to my cat.
Oh.
He is back and he's got a new trick.
Magical Trevor is ten times slick as the last time.
The last time you saw him.
Now you can see why I really adore him.
I say that except about my cat.
Like when my cat walks into a room I go...
He's back and he's got a new trick.
The lack of bounce is almost impressive.
I have a really good bra.
Okay.
That's what Doki said too.
We probably shop at the same place.
We probably have the same papa.
We're probably related.
Can I kindly request a cover of Numa Numa?
I think I've sung it in karaoke before.
I think I've sung Numa Numa in karaoke.
People's
bras.
Or something.
Seems like you do this...
Mushroom, mushroom.
Snake, it's a snake.
It's a snake.
All the internet.
I unfortunately had free reign.
During that time.
2000's meme karaoke.
That'd be fun.
The ultimate showdown of ultimate destiny.
You guys are so old.
Stop.
You too.
No, I'm a ghost.
I'm not aging.
I'm forever 19.
What's your age?
I saw... what was it?
Something the other day that I saw that was like...
It was like some boomer tweet that was like...
You guys don't understand.
Memes back in the day lasted a whole year.
They didn't last a week.
Memes back in the day meant something.
I wonder why.
I'm tired of pretending I'm not old.
I'm old.
Good luck at the concert, Minta.
I'll be traveling unfortunately, so I can't attend, but I'll be cheering for you.
Thank you, Andrew!
Why do memes like... It's so crazy.
There was like that chill dog that was recent.
Do you think she's aware that Niel C.
Cierga created ultimate battle and busting?
No way!
No way.
There
was like that chill dog.
And then like two days later, people were like, okay, it's over.
The meme is done.
I was like, what?
I just saw this guy for like the first time today.
What do you mean it's done?
What do you mean?
All your base... base... all your base are blondies.
Oh...
Chill dog was kind of annoying though.
Wait, why?
Why was he annoying?
He was so chill.
He got turned into crypto.
What?
Everything... All... All memes turn into crypto.
What happens?
Why does this happen?
Misuse.
Social media has killed memes faster than in the past.
Nori!
Welcome to memboyshop.
Thank you.
But it's crazy because like a lot of the older memes have like... I don't want to say survived, but they've...
They've carried on.
They've carried, you know?
Like some of the older ones, like... I mean, Rickroll for example.
Like...
That's so funny.
This is Sparta.
No!
That's what I hear.
That's actually what I think of every time I hear Sons of Sparta in DMC.
Oh gosh.
We need to bring back I'm on fire in Malaysia.
We need to bring that back.
I'm... Oh, you guys, you guys.
The game.
You guys just lost it.
Oh no.
So bad.
Maybe, you know what?
Maybe we don't need to bring it back.
Maybe we're fine.
It's only been a week since I lost it.
Why?
No!
It's kind of funny.
I didn't really watch any of those.
Like the Team Four Star and stuff like that.
The Yu-Gi-Oh and the Dragon Ball Z ones.
I never... It's funny because I was so into Yu-Gi-Oh.
I was so into Dragon Ball and just never really watched them.
John, thank you so much for the birthday gift!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much!
How?
I don't know.
I just... I don't know.
I just never watched them.
I can't remember what else I was watching back then.
DBZA, watch a long one.
Maybe I was watching Homestar Runner.
Maybe.
Hold on.
I'm gonna bring out another meme.
You know, I died when I was 19.
Thank God, too.
Can you imagine if I died earlier?
At least I can legally buy... I've died forever 19, so I could forever watch and play Eroge.
And buy Doujin.
I'm so glad that I died.
You know, and thought about that.
I mean, I didn't think about that, but you know, it's so convenient that that's...
That I died at such an age.
Thank goodness, right?
She can't drink in the US.
True?
And I... But I don't really drink, so...
Remember Weeble and Bop?
I know Weeble's stuff.
I'm so glad that I died.
Hello?
Or in Japan either.
Oh, true!
I was literally typing this super about to mention I'm a fire in my laser and then he said it.
Please get out of my head.
Get out of my head!
She can in Germany.
Okay.
What about Austria?
You can in most of Europe.
Let's go.
Wait, what's the drinking age in Canada?
Most of Europe is 18 plus.
Let's go.
19.
See?
If I want to drink, I just go somewhere else.
I just leave the country for a drink.
Easy peasy.
Basematara.
No.
Oh god, no.
Mentally, I'm in the EU.
What do you mean by that?
Visit Doki.
Oh gosh.
You guys are not making it much better.
Official Minto Eroge recommendation list when?
I couldn't recommend you much recent stuff though because I haven't played much recently.
You know?
Sad.
So sad.
There was... I don't know if I ever said this.
But before I graduated those years ago, you know?
I got offered...
I got offered a Steam key for an Eroge.
And I was like, yo, let's go.
I haven't played it yet.
Graduated.
Yeah, like, you know, I graduated and then I came back.
I graduated and went to heaven and then I came back.
Did you play it?
I played... Actually, that's a lie.
I played a little bit of it.
But I didn't, like, finish.
Wait, in more ways than one.
No, I'm just kidding.
But it's funny because the name is called Kiara and My Ara Ara Adventure.
I just got an email one day and they were like, hey, we're gonna give you this code.
And I'm like, I can't stream this.
But thank you.
Kiara and My Ara Ara Adventure.
So it's funny.
So now, you know, I would be like, we need like a Kiwawa mod for it.
Let's see.
Hold on.
If I go to the store...
Store page.
Has very positive reviews.
I could write a review.
But I would have to check the box because I received the product for free.
I just wanted you to have it.
Yeah, I was like, kind of surprised.
I was like, oh...
Thank you.
I was like, oh, okay, I'll take it.
It's like a, like a cat girl lady.
Sorry,
you heard nothing?
You didn't hear that?
Guys, thanks for today's stream.
I'm glad we could beat Merry Gear Solid.
And, of course, I'll do Merry Gear Solid 2 another day.
Maybe more towards Christmas when I, you know...
We'll beat it.
We'll beat that.
And we'll... yeah.
Yeah.
Sorry, that was for my PC.
What are you doing while you're watching me stream, huh?
Put that away.
I didn't realize that was your cue to... wait, that was my cue... wait.
The cue.
To believe me.
Believe me!
Eating stroganoff?
Oh, that sounds great.
I'm hungry too.
I'm gonna go eat dinner.
Put that away.
The program.
The game.
Your Ara Ara adventure.
Yeah, thanks for the tech gift.
Thank you.
Ghost never hungry.
Ghost always hungry.
I'm always hungry.
Otsumito everybody, thank you.
Maybe, you know what, maybe tonight I'll play the Ara Ara adventure and I'll tell you guys all about it.
How about that?
They were like, man, we really... all those years ago, four years ago, we really wished Mint would play the game and talk about it on stream.
I'll tell you all about it.
I'll tell you all about my adventure.
I did start a new book recently.
I think.
Hold on, let me see.
What was it?
I think... oh, I listened to it.
I fell asleep like five minutes in.
It was my minotaur husband.
I literally can't tell you a single thing about this.
No, I can't tell you a single thing about this book because I fell asleep.
I fell asleep immediately.
I put it on and went...
My minotaur husband.
Here, let's see what it's about.
Celeste is one of only a hundred remaining humans on Earth, living on a secured preserve away from many dangerous monsters out in the world.
But some monsters desperately want human companions, and they'll abide by all the strict rules and requirements to get one.
Celeste has applications piling up from those who want to court her.
But she's afraid of taking the leap... until Theo.
Theo, the minotaur, is shy, gentle, and kind, and wants nothing more than a human wife to spoil.
When Celeste agrees to move in and start a trial marriage, he'll do anything in his power to keep her happy and safe in a world where a human might make a great meal for another monster.
The only problem?
Theo is huge... in more than one way.
And he knows Celeste isn't ready for him yet.
It will take trust and time to prepare her.
She's a roast.
We must prepare the turkey.
As they start to build their new life together, and it might just lead to falling in love.
Oh, prepare the turkey.
Make me boneless like one of your French girls.
So yeah, maybe I'll listen to this and I'll play Chiara's Ara Ara Adventure.
Sounds like Celeste will need some ointment.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'll see you guys later.
This week, you know, this week coming up, a little more off days, not streaming days.
Because I'm going to Atlanta and then also doing a concert, so...
Busy, busy.
But I'll see you guys later!
Hello minto, hello!
Bye bye!
Thanks for streaming!
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye!